this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 79 sitting here with Echo Charles
EC Echo Charlie yes
let me Draco like contrarian thinking
is a is a tool I believe and the reason
I believe it's a tool
is because I think it allows us
to discover things that are
counter-intuitive which is positive
which you need help to get to get to you
need help finding counter intuitive
ideas and finding counter-intuitive
Solutions
you need help finding them
because they're by Nature counter
intuitive so your intuition is probably
wrong and you're thinking it's this but
it's not that and so you need help
finding counter-intuitive ideas and
solutions so
the reason is counterintuitive thinking
goes against conventional wisdom
sometimes it even goes against common
sense right there's times where you're
looking at a counter-intuitive idea and
it doesn't make sense this happens this
is a Bro Science Problem by the way sure
because bro you ever heard of bro
science explanation that makes 100 sense
yeah most of it and then someone just
presents actual facts to you
yes and you think Hmm I'm completely
wrong right so sometimes
intuitive thinking
is
wrong completely wrong
so even though it makes total common
sense but it doesn't work so I the
reason I bring this up is because I talk
about counter-intuitive Solutions a lot
the reason I probably end up spending a
lot of time talking about them and
explaining them to people and teaching
them is because they're counterintuitive
people don't get them easily
you want the team to buy into the plan
how do you get them to do that
the intuitive response is oh you first
of all you need to explain the why
there's a bunch of reasons that actually
make sense but the counter-intuitive one
is you let them come up with a plan and
as soon as people hear they think oh
yeah that's right
or here's another one that I've been
telling a lot of people lately you want
someone to listen to you
you want your team to listen to you how
do you get your team to listen to you
yell louder no
explain more explicitly no you want
someone to listen to you listen to them
counter-intuitive but it works
so
that's what counterintuitive is now
contrarian or contrarian thinking is
intentionally
going against the grain it's
intentionally going against popular
opinion and sometimes the the thing with
contrarian thinking is
it often
or actually the the goal of contrarian
thinking is to be against traditional
wisdom that's the goal of it the goal
isn't to be smarter the goal isn't to be
have a better plan the goal isn't to
have a better idea the goal isn't to
have a better solution the goal is just
to be concerned it's just to be against
traditional wisdom
whereas counterintuitive thinking is to
actually figure out what the best idea
idea is even if it happens to be against
the norm
so I worked for a guy one time that was
very contrarian
contrarian guy and and
it was good because it would get like
new ideas you know he'd throw something
out there it'd be a new idea and you'd
think it's cool but then I realized
after a little while that everything
that he said was the contrarian View and
he didn't care if it was going to take
more time he didn't care if it wasn't
the best idea it was just that it was
different
so
my recommendation is
to think like a contrarian so think as
contrarian as you can
so that you are able to see
counter-intuitive ideas but at the same
time don't be contrarian just for the
sake of being contrarian and don't get
stuck in the
in the zone
or in the lane don't get stuck in the
lane of being contrarian read Hoffman
he's a guy he's a uh a billionaire
venture capitalist
um guy from Greylock partners he founded
he founded LinkedIn so if you've heard
of him that's probably why you've heard
of him
he's attributed of using this phrase
encouraging people to have strong
beliefs loosely held
right so you have very strong belief but
you don't hold on to it
I think this is a good way to look at
being a contrarian
is like you're gonna think the opposite
but you're not gonna just think that way
try
hard to think of new ideas but don't get
married to them um
to be able to look at a problem be like
hey maybe we could do this a totally
different way
you know what's a great way to start off
with contrarian thinking when you're
trying to solve a problem is to just say
why do we even need to solve this
problem
yeah that's good like why do we even
need to do this
you ever heard someone uh actually was
who is it with oh is it Dr Luke
and we were talking about passing the
knee Shield you know guard Jiu Jitsu if
you're not a Jitsu player
and he was saying he was talking to Jeff
Glover and Jeff Glover was like how do I
you know he's like Jeff how do I get
past this
and he puts him in the knee shield and
then Jeff just steps back
all of a sudden there's no no more
initial it's gone yeah
why would you why do you he's that's the
answer
that Jeff is giving why do you even need
to get by that thing go a different way
so if you're looking at a problem if
you're looking at something that needs
planning if you're looking at something
that needs a solution anyway wait a
second why are we even trying to solve
this right now
you ever have that you know you you got
the guy who's trying to
uh figure out how to pick the lock to
the door
and then someone else is just like
slides open the window because it's open
yeah yeah you know it's like that kind
of thing why are you trying to solve
this
the way that you see this is
by being detached
by taking a contrarian look at something
uh
well here's another good little
contrarian statement to ask yourself
what if this was already done would we
be worried about it would we be thinking
about it right what would we be if this
wasn't if we weren't focused on this
right now if this just disappeared what
would we be focused on
all of a sudden you say wait a second
we're focused on something very small
that's right in front of us but it's not
going to really have a big impact over a
long long period of time
so those are some questions to ask
yourself to try and break yourself out
of normalized thinking
to try and get yourself in a contrarian
mindset
you know do we even need to do this is
there a totally different way to do this
what if this was already done those are
some questions you can ask yourself
and if you so that you can think like a
contrarian and you'll see New
Perspectives
but like I said don't get stuck there
don't be a person that is just going
against the grain just so they can go
against the grain that's annoying
yeah it's annoying yeah
I kind of like the idea of
like I said counter-intuitive
those are those are hard to find when
you find them they're more efficient
they're better
and sometimes you can find those
solutions by thinking in a contrarian
manner so there you go my topic for the
day
counterintuitive like there's a recently
kind of went down a little rabbit hole
with like decision making and one that
that was uh counterintuitive is that
more choices is better yep so you know
like uh and you know like most
counter-intuitive things when someone
can effectively explain it you're like
okay that makes sense it's not intuitive
but it makes sense with the explanation
but yeah the choices thing is a big one
if you have like three choices or two
choices that's the easy decision yeah or
it tends to be an easier decision but
that so there was this experiment where
I think this is what it was people from
the Ukraine I think they grabbed them
they said what's the differences here
and they had all these different brands
of soda and they're like it's like how
many choices do you have here they said
one choice
they're like why is it one choice
because you have choice of soda it does
like the differences between all this
soda or whatever is like there's no
choice there that's just soda and then
they said okay they have a bunch of
sodas they have orange juice and they
have a milk how many choices three
choices so they kind of went down like
why is this one choice they're different
brands they taste different or whatever
but in their mind I guess like it has a
lot to do with where you're from your
environmentalist stuff where that they
didn't didn't present as a bunch of
choices because that's not the routine
in regards to soda so it's like
interesting
well there's there's all kinds of when
it comes to having multiple choices it
is certainly
much easier to make a quick decision
between two choices yeah
is a lot and there's a there's a law for
this there's like one of those
theoretical laws and I can't remember
what it is but like if you have two
choices the amount of time it takes you
to select between A and B compared to a
b and c is a big exponential Factor yeah
so you want to minimize the number of
choices
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground